[Music]
our daily cancellation begins with one
of our favorite characters in this
segment lizzo except that for once the
story has almost nothing to do with
lizzo being naked and overweight as we
know she's built a career around
exploring the intersection of fatness
and nakedness but that is not the point
today rather lizzo has attracted
controversy because of some of the
lyrics in her new hit single
girls
spelled g-r-r-r-l-s
as we know lizzo almost certainly cannot
define the word girl
but perhaps she can define the word girl
i don't know but this is not the word
that has caused severe offense
consternation emotional trauma and even
we must assume physical injury to some
of uh of lizzo's fans
that word well i'm not gonna tell you
what that word is
partly because it's so deeply
problematic and shocking that i dare not
speak it out loud and also because i
thought it'd be a fun game
to play a one minute clip of the song
for you and i want you to guess
which lyric was so offensive that lizzo
had to issue a public apology and
re-release the song with this word
changed
so listen closely
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
bro
lizzo uh once again proving herself to
be the greatest poet of our time or any
time shakespeare may have written a
clever line or two but he never would
have thought to write something like
yeah we tussle mind your business zoo
zoo zoo zoo zoo zulu that's my girl we
ceos and dancing like a ce ho
only lizzo could come up with something
so profound and moving if shakespeare
had written that they would have you
know assumed he was having a stroke or
something but we're dancing around the
point here indeed i dare say we are we
are even dancing like ce hoes around the
point the question we still must answer
is which word out of all of the words
you just heard
though maybe bit too generous to call
all of those words
which was considered objectionable
enough to necessitate changing the song
she says the word [ __ ] multiple times
she uses the word hoe multiple times she
drops f-bomb she uses the term boozy
ratchet whatever the hell that means the
whole thing is about her engaging acts
of violence the song is one big threat
to jump some unspecified person and
commit felony assault or worse
and it's a potentially dangerous message
too because it might inspire other
out-of-shape women to pick random fights
with strangers thinking that they can
knock somebody out when they've never
thrown a punch in their lives and
probably will just break their wrists if
they tried
so
is that the problematic message
or how about the part where lizzo says
that she's gonna cut a man's penis off
so that he can never have sex again
that's pretty disrespectful is that the
offensive part
the entire song from beginning to end is
vulgar stupid and violent
she could scrap the whole thing and
replace all the lyrics with the sounds
of feral cats fighting inside a dumpster
and it would be a vast improvement over
what you just heard so
what is the specific line that caused
the problem
well it turns out
that the only offensive word in that
song was the word
spazz
now if you recall at the very beginning
she sings hold my bag hold my bag do you
see this
i'm a spaz
again
pure poetry
but that's the problem right there i'm a
spaz quite literally the least offensive
word in the entire song one of the only
lyrics that that we don't have to bleep
on this show is the word that people are
offended by of course as entertainment
weekly reports the term spazz is now as
of about 12 seconds ago uh considered an
ableist slur
in fact in their report entertainment
weekly censors the word much like they
would if it was the n word or the f word
which is still written out
in the in the article
but spazz or the s word as it will now
be known
is censored
many of lizzo's fans took her to task
for ableism in her song which promotes
felony violence and forced castration
but the real problem is the ableism
one of the fans leading the charge was
hannah divini a disability advocate with
pronouns in her bio and she tweeted a
couple of days ago she said hey lizzo my
disability cerebral palsy is literally
classified as [ __ ] dipl
diplegia where
specificity spasticity refers to
unending painful tightness in my legs
your new song makes me pretty angry and
sad spazz doesn't mean freaked out or
crazy it's an ableist slur
it's 20 22. do better
yes it's 2022.
you should know better than to use
harmless slang while threatening to cut
a man's penis off and beat stranger
senseless for no reason
please stick to communicating your
violent fantasies with vulgarities and
profanity just please just stick with
that
hannah is a woman of principle and
that's what she demands
and she got her way pretty quickly
yesterday lizzo reissued the song with
the s word replaced
and she made a public apology she posted
a twitter quote it's been brought to my
attention that there's a harmful word in
my new song girls let me make one thing
clear i never want to promote derogatory
language as a fat black woman in america
i've had many hurtful words used against
me so i overstand the power words can
have wait
i overstand
okay
i overstand the power words can have
whether intentionally or in my case
unintentionally i'm proud to say that
there's a new version of girls with a
lyric changed this is the result of me
listening and taking action
as an influential artist i'm dedicated
to being part of the change i've been
wanting and waiting to see in the world
only lizzo could manage to call herself
influential say that she's proud of
herself and brag about her wisdom and
insight
all in the context of an apology
truly the woman has turned virtue
signaling into an art form
she hasn't quite figured out how to make
her music into an art form but she's
basically the beethoven of virtue
signaling
at any rate yes uh be the change you
want to see in the world and lizzo
apparently
wants a world that is confused overly
sensitive and has its priorities exactly
backwards and upside down
and there's no doubt that she's
certainly helping in her own small way
to create precisely that kind of world
actually i need to correct myself
because i think we make a mistake when
we say that this sort of thing
is an example of people being sensitive
okay
and i and i say that all the time but
it's not exactly true because
traditionally
a sensitive person is somebody who is
empathetic kind um deeply aware of other
people's feelings and needs they're
affected by and will respond to
social cues
facial expressions and so on a sensitive
person is caring and compassionate
it's good to be sensitive in that way
and i say that as someone who is pretty
far to the other end of the spectrum for
better or worse
but i'm married to that sort of
sensitive person and i can say for sure
that the world would be a better place
if there were many more people like her
in the world like my wife that's why if
this was simply a case of people being
sensitive about the song
they might listen to it and object to
the whole thing observing that it's
vulgar and obscene and contributes to
the coarsening of our culture that would
be a sensitive and certainly not at all
unreasonable or baseless reaction to the
song and to almost everything else pop
culture produces but that's not what's
happening here
the people who who we often call
sensitive
are not sensitive at all
far from sensitive they're numb and dumb
they're more like robots filtering
everything through their leftist
programming and deciding based on those
algorithms to pretend to be offended by
all of the wrong things
this is how we end up in a culture
overrun by a bunch of inverted prudes
puritans who have been turned inside out
and flipped upside down
they have an endless appetite for
debauchery vulgarity stupidity obscenity
but they recoil in hard start firing off
angry letters because of some random
totally benign word or phrase that
happens to step on the intersectional
tripwire and set off the pc alarms
they celebrate christina aguilera
dancing around in front of children with
a strap-on dildo but if she had her hair
braided like in a you know a
dreadlocks or something
then they would demand a public apology
for cultural appropriation and hairstyle
colonialism
this is the kind of sensitivity we're
talking about and it's not sensitivity
at all
but insanity
i think that's what we should really be
saying
and that is why not just lizzo but
everybody involved in this story
is today
cancelled
and you're all a bunch of spazzes too
might i add well let me ask you
something what if there was someone out
there who kept the log of every single
thing you did every minute of the day i
think that'd be pretty creepy well what
if i told you that's exactly what
happens every time you go online your
internet provider like at t or comcast
is allowed to store logs of every
website you've ever visited and they can
legally sell this data to anyone they
want that's why i always use expressvpn
expressvpn reroutes your internet
connection through their secure server
so your internet provider can't see or
log what you're doing online now many of
you if you're more perceptive you might
be wondering well if i'm routing all my
data through a vpn then doesn't the vpn
get to log and see all my data and
you're right to think that way many vpns
claim to have a no logs policy but have
been caught logging customer activity
anyway expressvpn is the only vpn i
trust because they use trusted server
technology stop letting people keep logs
of what you do online visit
expressvpn.com walsh yt right now and
find out how you can get three months
free for our cancellation today we head
up to a ranch in montauk new york where
horses and obesity have combined to
create a perfect cancellation
storm perfect conditions for
cancellation nbc news has the important
story it says remy uh remy bader a tick
tock star known for her realistic
clothing haul videos
i actually have to stop right there
because um we haven't even finished the
first sentence but
realistic clothing haul videos
i'm not sure what a clothing haul video
is i'm even less sure how such a video
could be unrealistic in the first place
do most tick tock stars in the clothing
hall genre use special effects or cgi
is she a pioneer of like gritty
live-action
clothing haul videos these are questions
we don't have time to investigate
because there are larger problems to
deal with continuing
remy barber bader a tick-tock star known
for her realistic clothing haul videos
claimed that during a recent trip with
other influencers a ranch wouldn't allow
her to ride their horses due to her
weight
bader who has more than 2 million
followers on tik tok was in montauk new
york with other influencers on a trip
organized by the company hampton water
wine over the weekend when she said she
was turned away
now i'm imagining being stuck on a
camping trip or a hiking trip with
tick-tock influencers organized by a
company called hampton water wine and
i'm just filled with dread and despair
at the thought of it
i'd probably just steal one of the
horses and ride off into the sunset
never to be seen again that is assuming
all the horses hadn't been crushed to
death already because that's what this
woman apparently feels she has the right
to do to horses reading more it says in
her initial tic toc post on saturday
bader shared a video of the ranch with
the text over it saying
shout out to deep hollow ranch and
montauk for making me leave because i
weigh over 240 pounds
videos received over 1.5 million views
the caption reads i've rode horses
before and i have never had an issue
she asked them to advertise on their
signs in the future
yes they ought to advertise that on
their signs
this is their fault for not putting
something on their signs indicating that
they'd prefer if their horse's spines
were left intact
because of this oversight remy felt
entitled to publicly bash this small
business as a result the company is now
being flooded with negative yelp reviews
which by the way is a potentially fatal
blow to any business of this size
after launching this attack and
receiving blowback in her own direction
she then claimed that her beef isn't
with the weight limit itself but with
the abrupt and insulting way in which
she was informed of the weight limit
it's not what they said but how they
said it she now claims
and for its part the ranch initially had
no comment instead a teenage employee
took it upon himself to issue his own
rebuttal to this woman and i'll just say
that his
his pr skills could use a little bit of
work let's watch
[Laughter]
when you're not a fat you can ride a
deep ollie ranch
well
you know that was rude certainly and the
video has been deleted as you'd expect
the ranch has apologized for it and uh
we could probably assume the kid was
fired but remy was determined to get the
last word the next day she clapped back
as the kids say with this rebuttal
um if you don't like me that's fine
but
you know watch him out
two million view uh followers on that
account
in summary a lot of very stupid people
are involved in this story as is so
often the case for the things we talk
about during this segment and during
every other segment of the show but
there are a couple of points i think to
be made here the first is that not every
personal gripe needs to be presented to
the entire world
so let's just pretend for a moment that
remy was completely polite and
accommodating maybe she didn't know that
horses have weight limits maybe she
thought that horses have spines made of
reinforced steel and she just didn't
realize that this was a thing and maybe
she was very understanding when they
informed her of this matter and only
became upset because they were rude and
insulting about it even if that's the
case
why does the world need to be involved
in this dispute why why would you want
the world to be involved aren't you
embarrassed that you were turned away
from a horse ranch because you exceed
the weight limit
if that were me i would go home and pray
that nobody posts anything about the
incident online i certainly wouldn't be
posting about it myself and tell people
about it
but as much as people these days pretend
to care so much about privacy
like we've never talked about privacy as
much as we do in in our society
yet the fact is that most people want
anything but privacy in fact most people
fear privacy
privacy to them is akin to annihilation
annihilation
if they don't post everything online
they'll cease to be they think
they have an answer to the old tree
falling in a forest question if nobody
hears it it doesn't make a sound that's
their opinion just as if nobody knows
about every single thing that's
happening to them
they don't exist
that's why people will willingly post
the sorts of things that people of
previous generations would have died to
keep out of public view
there are no boundaries no shame
especially for influencers whose
livelihood depends on making a spectacle
and controversy out of everything that
happens to them but of course i don't
buy that this person was polite and
reasonable and only upset because of the
rudeness of the staff at the ranch
pretty clear at least initially that she
was simply mad that they wouldn't let
her ride the horses from her perspective
it is well worth sacrificing the
physical well-being of a horse in order
to protect her own emotional well-being
as ben shapiro pointed out in his
reaction to the story these are the
wages of expressive individualism
of course expressive individualism is
the defining philosophy of the modern
age we talk about it all the time on
this show even if not by that name it's
what carl truman elucidates so
brilliantly in his book the rise and
triumph of the modern self he also talks
about it in my film what is a woman
according to expressive individualism a
person is totally defined by
his psychological state
his feelings his self-perception
the primary point of life really the
only point is to protect and affirm and
reinforce that psychological state lives
are lived inwardly everybody is looking
back within themselves all the time
reflecting constantly on their own inner
experience all that matters is the inner
experience
whatever must be done to improve that
experience the one felt inside the one
perceived by the mind
even if it not always reflected in
reality doesn't matter whatever must be
done for its sake
should be done that's all
all that matters to the expressive
individual is their own psychological
comfort
to live authentically
is to live in a way that expresses their
current psychological state and makes
them feel better about it
and if that means crushing a horse it
means crushing a horse
yes you know horses have weight limits
in physical reality but in the mind of
this plus-sized rider on the saddle
there is no weight limit
they can do anything that anybody else
can do
that's how they perceive the world
and themselves and everybody else's job
is to conform to that perception
this mentality obviously has
consequences far far beyond potential
spinal injuries to horses but uh you
know that is one of the that's
collateral damage there's a lot of
collateral damage left behind as the
expressive individual goes about her
life making herself feel better about
herself and never worrying about
anything else least of all horses
and that is why she is today finally